nearly every minute a child aged five or
younger dies of malaria most of them in
Africa a new vaccine developed by Oxford
University and manufactured in India
hopes to change that but the speed at
which it's been approved in Ghana and
without World Health Organization
endorsement has some worried so
so what is the government up to I will
not allow my children to be vaccinated
we have heard about children dying or
left with physical deformities after
taking some medicines and vaccines is
the government thinking about the safety
of our children at all I will only use
the vaccine after countries have gone
through the trials and the who approves
it scientists at Oxford say research
suggests the r21 jab is 75 effective
detailed data from large-scale trials is
not yet publicly available but Ghana's
government is confident it's made the
right decision we are talking about two
hundred thousand three hundred thousand
four hundred thousand children dying of
malaria every year and if you can save
even half of that number with a vaccine
that is not as efficient as you want it
to be that is still good enough okay so
r21s approval of organized FDA is not so
much out of place although their wish
would have been that we waited a bit for
The Who to do the artistic
the who says regulatory authorities from
at least 10 African countries are
considering the vaccine scientists say
that jab can be produced at Mass scale
and relatively low cost it's already
undergone trials in the UK Thailand and
several African nations the FDA with all
its capacities and competencies
certainly has looked at the dostia that
was presented to it
and
I have no doubt that they basically
their their decision on what was in the
dossier unfortunately that dose here
that was shared with FDA Ghana and
indeed Nigeria was not was not she has
not been shared with us as who
The Who approved the world's first
malaria vaccine moscricks last year but
a lack of funding has delayed its role
out and with around 660
000 people dying from the mosquito-borne
disease every year countries are
desperate to find an alternative Alex
beard Al Jazeera